[موسيقى]
لطالما شكلت اصابه الاهداف البعيده هواجس
لدى جيوش العالم فحركت العقول لاختراع
قذيفه القنابل الاتوماتيكيه التي بدات
بالقاء القنابل البسيطه وباتت السلاسل
المتطوره منها ربما الاسلحه الاكثر خطوره
فكيف نشات
ظهرت فكره
يدويه في بدايه القرن العشرين وكان
البريطانيون اول من فكر بذلك ولكنه لم
ينقل للواقع حتى عام
1928 حيث بدا الجيش الاحمر باستخدام
منظومه قاذفه قنابل بندقيه ذات مدن من 150
الى 850 متر
اما اول قاذفه قنابل اليه اي جي ال فظهرت
في الثلاثينيات بفضيا كوفت بين وهو طالب
جامعي من بلا روسيا حيث كشف اثناء تدريب
العسكري قدرته على انتاج سلاح يرسل
القنابل بطريقه اوتوماتيكيه في عام
1931 صمم تبين قاذفه القنابل الاولى اي جي
ال وفي عام
1933 تم انجازها تم تثبيت قاذفه القنابل
في البدايه على حامل ثلاثي القوائم
واستبدلت لاحقا لقاذفه موشاه خفيفه على
عجلات فاستحقت بين وظيفه مصمم عسكري
استخدم الاختراع الجديد في الحرب
السوفيتيه الفنديه بنطاق محدود كما تم
انتاج كميه جيده منه للاسطول العسكري لكن
العمل عليه توقف بسبب تغيير الاداره
الداعمه للفكره بالجيش كما ان توبين اتهم
بالتخطيط لانتاج انظمه اسلحه غير مكتمله
تقنيا وغير مرضيه واعدم رميا بالرصاص في
عام
1941 كما لم يعد هذا السلاح يذكر الى ان
استخدم الامريكيون سلاحا مشابها عام
1967 وهي قاذفه القنابل الاتوماتيكيه ب 40
ملم بزيت نعم
كانت القاذفه الامريكيه ام كي 19 ثقيله
ويصعب التعامل معها ومع ذلك كانت مثالا
لمصمميه المدفعيه اليدويه سريعه النيران
في الدول الغربيه كما كانت سببا في ان
يعمل الروس على منتجه من القديم والخروج
بتصميم قاذفه اي جي اس 17 التي استخدمت في
الحرب الافغانيه
مقارنه بنظيرتها الامريكيه كانت قذفه اي
جي اس 17 اقل وزنا واكثر فعاليه خصوصا بعد
ان خضعت لسلسله من التعديلات فتمت اضافه
فتاه ومصفاه ذكيه واصبحت اكثر امانا بحيث
لا تنفجروا اذا طارت اقل من 30 متر لم
تنجح قادفه اي جي اس 17 بالمناطق الحضاريه
حيث لا يوجد وقت لسحب قذيفه قنابل وزنها
رطل فتم العمل على تطوير قاذفه القنابل
الاحداث اي جي اس 30 التي تمتعت بمعدل
اطلاق النار اعلى ب 4 مرات
شهدت القاذفه الجديده رواجا في سوق السلاح
العالميه وفي عام
1971 تم اعتمادها رسميا من قبل الجيش
السوفيتي حتى 40 عاما لاحقا
في عام
1980 تم اعتماد قاذفه المروحيات
213 بي وهي عباره عن قاذفه قنابل اليه
ايجي اس 17 موجوده في حاويه معلقه بطائره
روحيه
اليوم ومع توفر الامكانيات التكنولوجيه
الحديثه ظهرت انواع عديده ومختلفه من
قاذفات القنابل الاتوماتيكيه وربما اكثر
خطوره من قبل ولاسيما اذا ما جرى الحديث
عن حادثه القنابل النوويه الروسيه تو 22
ام ثلاثه
[موسيقى]